et les sages se penchent donc
actuellement sur le texte et plusieurs
de ses dispositions controversées dont
l'extension du passani terre aux
activités du quotidien
dans quelques jours il sera notamment
exigé pour accéder aux terrasses des
bars et des restaurants
les gérants s'y prépare le cas légers
les restaurateurs se prépare à mettre en
application le pass sanitaires pour les
terrasses mais malgré une forte hausse
des vaccinations depuis annonces faites
par emmanuel macron le 12 juillet des
incertitudes demeurent sur l'avenir dans
ce restaurant du 9e arrondissement de
paris tout est prêt pour accueillir les
clients selon les nouvelles règles
ce dont on est coincé mon content c'est
que le gouvernement est absolument
entendu qu'on n'avait pas besoin et en
légumes ne fallait pas qu'on contrôlent
les identités ça c'est pas du tout notre
rôle en revanche contrôles et les passes
sanitaire pourquoi pas bien sûr on le
fera et avec aucun sens aucun problème
quoi s'il faut refuser et il faut
indiquer à des personnes qu'elles ne
peuvent pas venir voir un endroit où
tout le monde a fait l'effort de venir
avec un pass and i ter dont on essaiera
de le faire avec le plus de diplomatie
possible c'est pas ça on essaiera de
faire le mieux possible
voilà alors que l'extension du pass
sanitaire fait l'objet d'un mouvement de
contestation qui prend de l'ampleur
certains professionnels refusent
purement et simplement de se soumettre
aux dispositifs sur le portail anima
point fr six mille professionnels
revendiquent leur refus de contrôler
leurs clients parmi eux des
restaurateurs que j'ai adhéré totalement
insipide et de d'être restaurateurs et
non pas agent de police si j'avais voulu
faire agents de police nationale était
restaurateur f que les pouvoirs publics
vont imposer toute forme de coercition
pas en forme qui il
je vais peut-être être obligé de me
plier mais tant que je pourrai les
folles l'initiative n'est pas passé
inaperçu au sommet de l'état le 22
juillet le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin avait mis en garde dans
un tweet les établissements référencés
sur anima point fr détournement
scandaleux de la règle commune nous ne
sortirons de la crise qu par le civisme
collectif ces lieux recensés seront donc
contrôlée en priorité et les sanctions
prévues par la loi sont dissuasives
les contrevenants risquent sept jours de
fermeture administrative et jusqu'à un
an de prison
et 9000 euros damende s'ils se font
épingler plus de trois fois dans les 45
jours